how does this Paris deal actually change
the landscape not only for bankers but
for markets and companies well I think
the signal is just as strong as it
possibly could be you know I've been in
this business of working in the UN and
in the World Bank for a long time now
and it's just so rare that 196 countries
can come together and agree on something
and what's especially important is that
we went in really with our fingers
crossed hoping that there'd be some kind
of an agreement but this agreement went
far beyond what any of us had hoped this
is as powerful a signal as that anyone
could send that we are serious now about
tackling climate change but so what sort
of developments should we be looking at
for the financial markets well I think I
think what we're gonna see is that there
is a very strong commitment now to find
low-carbon solutions to solving just
about any kind of problem let me just
give you one example of one of the
things that's going to happen you know
China has committed to a national carbon
trading program by 2017 you know the day
that happens and we know a will because
President Xi said it will happen that's
going to be the largest carbon market in
the history of the world and so the
message is from there from everywhere it
can be very strong the World Bank is
also one of the biggest funders of green
projects does this deal change anything
for you absolutely so the the ambition
was was was scaled up at this at this
historic meeting so now now we're not
just shooting for 2 degrees Celsius
we're shooting for as much as 1.5
degrees Celsius so in other words we
have to get much more serious everywhere
we work about finding low carbon
solutions our investments in renewable
energy have to go up we've got to find
ways of making deals around geothermal
energy around hydroelectric power so I
think they're gonna be a lot of very
powerful economic opportunities
investment opportunities for the private
sector all over the world you see
companies already moving in that
direction Paul Polman of Unilever has
moved the entire company in that
direction
the the oil and gas companies throughout
Europe have already been talking to us
thinking about how they can remake their
businesses so that they are part of this
low-carbon future
dr. Kim weather in Washington or Dubai
New York or London it's a wonderful step
from Copenhagen what do you need to get
to the next step and to be less
optimistic about it do you need crisis
like the pollution in Beijing to drive
the conversation forward you know Tom
there's no question that the fact that
the red alert happened you know right
during the meeting did have an impact
the other thing that had a big impact
was a representative the small island
developing countries the Marshall
Islands in particular really led a
conversation that basically said look
this is real today it's not something
that's going to happen in the future
this is happening right now we're facing
extinction as nation-states so the
crisis is ongoing and I think that's
really a big part of what what would
push the depression over so the science
is much more powerful right now than it
was even a couple of years ago the
science is better now
even than a few years ago that this is
real and it's happening faster than we
thought well I would agree with you that
the science is much better tell me about
the politics right now and what does
this meeting in future meetings need
mean for the oil states such as Abu
Dhabi well you know there's no question
that there will that fossil fuels will
be part of the transition it will be
part of the movement toward a low-carbon
future we can't stop using fossil fuels
now but what we're what we're hoping for
is that with things like the carbon
trading scheme in China and a growing
movement to put a price on carbon
because we actually know that when you
put carbon in the air it does exact a
price it does cost us to do that as
carbon pricing gains momentum' I think
that the market forces will align very
very powerfully and every every producer
of oil and gas is going to have to face
that reality now again as I said it's
not something that's going to be cut off
immediately but every country in the
world has to now think about this
low-carbon future even the Gulf
countries dr. Kim when we look at some
of the figures six
Tina point five trillion dollars what we
understand by 2030 some of the figures
that we need to respond to climate
change what do you make of those numbers
are is it doable will it put a huge
strain on the world economy well you
know we've got just to put in clearer
perspective but by 2030 there is about
90 trillion dollars worth of
infrastructure that we have to build and
what we now realize is that all that
infrastructure has to be climate
resilient climate smart and has to be
done with respect to this agreement you
know that this is not about a
development aid I think one of the
things that happened during these talks
and we put this on the table is that
this is not about grants coming from
rich countries to poor countries we've
got to get creative for example at the
World Bank Group what we need to now do
is to use our capital more creatively so
that for example if we can use donor
assistance or even our concessional
loans as risk capital for major
infrastructure projects that will be
much more climate smart you know that's
going to be the wave of the future I
think there are real opportunities for
investors in this climate smart future
but they've got to become literate
they've got to now understand what this
deal means and they've got to understand
the opportunities that come out of it I
really believe that there will be
tremendous opportunities but the fact
that 196 countries that have a hard time
agreeing on anything they agreed on this
extremely ambitious plan it means that
everyone has got to become climate
literate right now